the entire Elizabeth Warren Native
American situation has completely
exploded or imploded I guess depending
on your perspective for her in terms of
the PR situation to remind you of the
backstory Elizabeth Warren has for a
long time claimed some a partial Native
American Cherokee ancestry
this was called into question by
different right-wingers it was also an
issue whether she had at any point
received this sort of affirmative action
advantage as a result of claiming that
Native American heritage or ancestry a
few months ago she took and released a
DNA test which in and of itself may have
also been a mistake the idea was get it
sort of out of the way before she
announces her run for president the DNA
test showed a likely Native American
ancestor somewhere between six and ten
generations ago the entire story has led
to some Cherokee leaders being angry
saying that she's using the DNA test to
try to justify a connection to the tribe
that even if you can defend genetically
as valid is not valid in terms of her
actual cultural connection to the tribe
not all Cherokee elders that have spoken
about this take that perspective but
some do and then now on top of all of
this it was revealed yesterday that the
State Bar of Texas registration that
Elizabeth Warren filled out by hand when
she became a member of the bar as an
attorney in Texas she wrote that her
race is American Indian the document
which we are showing to our television
audience is written in blue ink in
handwriting that is both believed to be
Elizabeth Warren's and has not been
denied the authenticity of this document
that we're showing you has not been
called into question by Elizabeth
Warren's
office and it says race American Indian
so this is now the first document that
actually shows her claiming she's a
Native American in her own handwriting
we know that at Harvard and I believe at
UPenn
she was listed as native-american in
certain internal documents although
those were not documents that were used
to make a determination as to whether
she is going to be accepted or not
accepted hired or not hired or anything
like that um so Elizabeth Warren now is
in the position of saying she apologizes
for labeling herself Native American at
UPenn and at Harvard and we are
eventually going to have to hear
something probably about this document
as well so I think it's important to
break this down piece by piece because
this is mostly a PR disaster for
Elizabeth Warren but it's going to have
an impact or very well may if indeed she
becomes the Democratic nominee question
one did Elizabeth Warren gain anything
by registering as a Native American with
the Texas State Bar doesn't appear that
way I mean this is for statistical
purposes period did Elizabeth Warren
gain an advantage at UPenn or Harvard
for being listed as Native American
appears the answer is also no that was
something that was done after she
started there it wasn't an affirmative
action or diversity candidate thing in
any way so is this actually a big deal
no it's not a lot of people in the
United States believe that they have
Native American heritage genuinely I
just had a friend who thought she was
significantly Native American did her
DNA test that showed something about the
same as Elizabeth Warren okay is
Elizabeth Warren smart enough to realize
that taking a DNA test
that won't show she's Native American is
a bad idea
I'm sure she realizes that I believe she
took the DNA test assuming it would
confirm that she's Native American since
that's the family history that she was
told this doesn't relate to her fitness
as a senator this doesn't relate to her
fitness as a potential president she was
presented with facts about her DNA and
she has now apologized but it has been a
massive PR blunder and she is suffering
and she probably will continue to suffer
for it now she's done the right thing
she claimed something
she was presented with contradictory
data she has apologized for it period
the problem is that it gives Trump and
the right huge ammunition I'm not making
the case that it's a great thing to
criticize the little Elizabeth Warren
because she mistakenly asserted Native
American heritage I don't think it's
really going to hurt her in the
Democratic primary at least I hope that
it doesn't I'm going to continue
evaluating candidates on their merits
and positions but if Elizabeth Warren
becomes the Democratic nominee and I
don't want to play electability games
but I'm just reporting on this
particular story and remember she's one
of my top picks so if I'm playing
electability games I'm hurting the the
person one of the people that I like if
she becomes the Democratic nominee Trump
is going to make an issue of this
Republicans are going to make an issue
of this the right is going to make an
issue of this and it will be a disaster
is it an adage a stir that will
ultimately sink her attempt to be
president probably not by itself but it
is going to be something that the right
will focus on you would better believe
it so it is a pretty big PR disaster I
don't know who's advising her I know
some of her advisors and I haven't
spoken to them about where she's come up
with what to do and say around this
entire story but blowing up as just a
series of bad decisions from something
that in all likelihood was a truly
innocent belief based on the stories her
family has told that she had Native
American ancestry if I miss reading the
story let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
one of today's sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below